june 18 1954 as dawn broke over the
country of guatemala a plane suddenly
swooped over the sleeping capital
guatemala city as it passed over the
national palace the plane dropped
thousands of pamphlets into the air
confused citizens and police officers
began to pick them up and what they read
was ominous
if guatemala's president jacobo arbenz
didn't resign by the afternoon that same
plane would return to bond the city and
the national palace
signed by the national liberation forces
a few hours later president arbenz heard
the news
a plane had just attacked one of
guatemala's port cities and an army of
insurgents had crossed into guatemala
their banner read god father land and
liberty
arbenza's greatest fear had come true
the invasion had begun and they were
coming for his head
june 27 1954 after nine days of
bombing's guerrilla fight and
psychological warfare president arbenz
got his final ultimatum surrender or
death
he was surrounded by an invading army
without any military support of his own
and he knew he was finished
at around 9pm he addressed the nation
over radio and the second democratically
elected president of guatemala stepped
down from his position and went into
exile
monopolies
on paper the downfall of guatemala
looked like just some trouble in a far
away country that no one cares about but
in reality it was a coup orchestrated by
none other than the cia
that part is not very surprising the
shocking part is how a us fruit company
lobbied the us government to overthrow
the guatemalan government because they
were threatening the u.s fruit company's
profits yes a fruit company helped
overthrow a sovereign government to
protect their bottom
line after the invasion guatemala fell
back into the hands of a brutal military
regime and for the following decades
terror poverty and assassinations
dominated the country all with the
blessing of the cia and the united fruit
company
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime with my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
all you have to do is follow me on
instagram at jaketran and you're
automatically entered watch out for fake
accounts i will never message you asking
for money or to invest and this is how
the u.s stole guatemala
[Music]
[Music]
right now everyone is struggling to save
money especially with the super high gas
prices and inflation and one of the
easiest ways to save money is by
cancelling subscriptions that you no
longer use that sounds great and all but
if you're like me you have too many
subscriptions to keep track of but that
is where true build comes in true build
is an all-in-one personal finance app
that has saved me and 2 million other
users a lot of money we're talking over
100 million dollars saved and counting
check this out all you have to do is
link your bank account true bill will
analyze and list out all the
subscriptions you have and how much
they're costing you and then you can
cancel the ones you don't need without
ever leaving the true build up it saves
you money time and the hassle of dealing
with an annoying cancellation process
it's my favorite feature of true build
by far and i use it all the time because
i have way too many subscriptions to
keep track of my other favorite feature
is how true bill would negotiate your
bills down for you super cool just
select the bill you want to lower take a
picture of your bill or enter your
information manually and true bill will
get to work right away negotiating your
bill down for you true bill has an 85
success rate in lowering bills and if
they're successful you get to choose how
much of those savings you want to pay
the true bill for their services i
usually choose 50 of whatever they save
me and there are a ton of other great
features on proud top promotes like
tracking your credit score net worth or
even setting up an automatic savings
fund that you can withdraw from any time
all you have to do to get started is
pause the video and go to truebuild.com
jake with the link below that's
truebuild.com with the link below so
they know i sent you thanks to truebill
for sponsoring this video
in may 1944 guatemala's dictator general
obiko was facing a serious problem he
had been oppressing guatemala's poor
citizens for over a decade but it seemed
like people finally had enough of the
corrupt military regime they wanted a
government that worked for the people
instead of just lining their own pockets
so guatemala citizens took matters into
their own hands and began to demonstrate
they wanted rubiko out and what does a
dictator do when people start to oppose
him he puts his military to use
as people gathered in the main square
demanding that the dictator must go he
gave his military a clear order show
these pesky protesters what happens when
you stand up to the government then all
hell broke loose the military began to
shoot into the crowd as if they were
fighting off an invading army and around
200 people were killed or injured but
this ruthless act of violence only
strengthened the people's will and they
kept coming for him and on july 1st
stunned by the opposition to his rule
ubiko resigned as president and turned
over power to his general federico ponce
but people quickly realized that he was
just another tyrant with a different
name nothing had changed after a few
months passed one of guatemala's best
journalists had decided that he had seen
enough so he launched a series of bold
articles and fiery speeches criticizing
the corrupt regime from all sides not
surprisingly a few days later he was
found dead assassinated on government
orders the guatemalans were outraged
under rising pressure from the public
general ponce agreed to hold a free
election and people immediately began to
look for the right candidate to run
against him they needed someone who
could put the country on the right path
and they soon found their ideal
candidate dr jose arrival a teacher who
had been living in exile in argentina
for 14 years
his books and political vision were well
known and respected throughout guatemala
and he quickly became the nation's last
hope the man who might finally put an
end to corruption and poverty in their
country when he arrived in guatemala he
was welcomed like a hero but it didn't
last long general ponce heard about the
euphoria and sent his military to arrest
him so arevalo immediately had to go
into hiding but while the general was
trying to get rid of his main competitor
his own fate was being sealed by two
young officers one of which would later
become the president of guatemala jacobo
arbenz
he had fled guatemala months earlier to
plan a revolt and now it was time to
chase the corrupt government out of the
country the two officers gave weapons to
supporters of the revolution and
launched guerrilla attacks against
police stations and after a few days of
fighting general ponce accepted a deal
with the rebels guatemala's first free
election would soon take place there
would be no corruption no violence no
bribes
after a landslide victory the general
was sent packing home and the people's
candidate dr jose arevelo became the
first elected president of guatemala and
he immediately went to work guatemala's
citizens got more rights censorship was
forbidden and racial discrimination was
made a crime but the biggest challenge
was the devastating poverty of the
country guatemala's people relied
heavily on agriculture for their
survival the problem was that about two
percent of landowners owned more than 70
percent of the land and much of it was
uncultivated so while a few wealthy
landowners were living in luxury 99 of
the people were starving lifting
guatemala out of poverty would require
an all-out attack on land ownership but
the problem was most of this land wasn't
owned by wealthy guatemalans no no no
that land was owned by one of america's
most powerful companies and luckily for
that company attacking private land
ownership sounded a lot like communism
something that america was vehemently
fighting against
after president arevalo had served his
term jacobo arbenz became guatemala's
second elected president the man who
helped win the revolution
in 1950 jacobo arbenz was voted
president he wasn't a communist but some
of his close allies were
a former military man arbenz sought to
modernize guatemala's backward society
and the critical issue of land reform
now laid in his hands and he wasted no
time going to war with the american
company that owned the most land in
guatemala the united fruit company
while most of guatemala's people were
struggling to survive the united fruit
company owned half a million acres of
land the railroads and the port
any business that wanted to export goods
had to use their infrastructure so they
had nearly total control over the
country's trade the fruit company was
also in the habit of forming close ties
with corrupt dictators to get special
deals they bribed politicians pressured
the government and intimidated opponents
to get their way while ruthlessly
exploiting the country and its people
but their new president jacobo arbenz
was about to shake the status quo in
october 1951 a top executive of the
fruit company arrived in guatemala from
boston to negotiate a new deal he talked
to president arbenz as if he was his
assistant and demanded the best terms
for his company the message was clear
you may be the president but we the
united fruit company are who really run
this country and you better do as we say
but president arbenz was having none of
it he made him a different offer improve
the docs reduce the freight rates and
start paying more taxes shocked at these
wild demands the executive hurried back
to boston for the fruit company it was a
declaration of war
in march 1953 the united fruit company's
worst fears came into fruition president
arbenz started the long-awaited land
reform he seized over 200 000 acres of
uncultivated fruit company land and
distributed it amongst the peasants
based on the tax value of the land
arbenz was willing to pay the fruit
company about 630 000 in bonds the fruit
company's response a formal complaint
but not by the united fruit company but
the u.s state department they found the
offer offensive and demanded 16 million
yes this fruit company was so powerful
that the u.s state department was
negotiating on their behalf that's how
big they were but president arbenz
wasn't in the mood for concessions and
only a few months later he seized even
more united fruitland now the company's
executives in boston start to get
nervous how dare he threaten our
prophets united fruit executives began
to discuss the issue with their
connections in washington and they all
came to the same conclusion president
arbenz was a threat to u.s prophets i
mean freedom we have to prevent
communism from spreading and not before
long a conclusion was reached in the u.s
government
president our benz must go but even
though we're talking about the
all-powerful united states they couldn't
just send a few thousand u.s marines to
invade the country sure the invasion
would be over in a few hours but it
would be a pr nightmare an act of war a
violation of international law so if the
u.s wanted to dispose of the guatemalan
president they had to be more strategic
about it if you want to overthrow a
foreign government you must first bring
the people behind you you need to make
sure that everyone sees guatemala as the
enemy a threat to america a threat to
everyone's freedom and how do you do
that with a propaganda campaign against
president arbenz
[Music]
became increasingly communistic after
its inauguration in 1951.
communists in the congress and high
governmental positions controlled major
committees labor and farm groups and
propaganda facilities
they agitated and led in demonstrations
against neighboring countries in the
united states
[Music]
convincing the public and the u.s
president to overthrow a foreign
government takes a true marketing genius
someone who knows how to manipulate the
masses and doesn't shy away from using
dirty tricks and who would be better
suited for that task than the man who
got american women to smoke a man named
edward bernays
in the 1920s smoking was a big taboo for
women but thanks to bernay's propaganda
and marketing skills he got women to
smoke all over the country he basically
doubled the tobacco industry's revenue
overnight it was such a huge success
that it turned him into an undisputed
marketing legend and now it was time for
bernice's next big coup a pr campaign to
justify an invasion of guatemala and he
brought out the big guns right from the
start
he warned that dozens of communists had
snuck into arbenz's regime secretly
controlling his every move he claimed
that arbenz was a puppet of the soviet
union and that a complete soviet
takeover was about to happen he painted
a picture of communism spreading all
over america like a virus and that
everyone's freedom was at stake all
because of guatemala
bernays dominated the pr war in a brutal
fashion and guatemala they simply
watched in fear while not being able to
do anything to present their side of the
story but bernays wasn't the only pr
weapon of the united fruit company in
1953 they began writing a confidential
newsletter in guatemala's politics and
economy and they wrote themselves into a
frenzy
united fruit paid 35 000
for a report that was sent to members of
the u.s congress and hundreds of
washington's decision makers it was full
of wild claims and theories that the
soviet union was taking over guatemala
and that they had to strike now before
communism would conquer the entire
american continent these reports soon
found their way to the highest ranks of
the cia and thanks to the ties between
the u.s state department the cia and the
united fruit company it didn't take long
to get the green light for their mission
us secretary of state dulles takes the
rostrum to urge united action by the
americas to outlaw international
communist intervention in the western
hemisphere this conference was shocked
by the dastardly attack on members of
the united states congress by those who
professed to be patriots
they may not themselves have been
communists but they had been subjected
to the inflammatory influence of
communism which aboutly uses extreme
nationalism as one of its tools
code name operation success target
president arbenz objective get him out
of the presidential palace dead or alive
first the cia thought about killing
arbenz with a silent bullet but they
knew it could turn him into a martyr and
cause a new revolution so it was off the
table the next idea was to bribe arbenz
out of office
we're talking about a weak president in
central america after all of course he
would accept money over death so they
transferred huge amounts of money into a
swiss bank account and told arbenz that
it was time to enjoy life but
unfortunately they were dealing with a
man of integrity and he refused
next the cia tried to sow division in
his military
the u.s knew that arbenza's survival was
dependent on the loyalty of his men and
once they realized they were fighting
for a lost cause they would put down
their weapons but that plan also failed
his men were too loyal and unwilling to
move against him at this point
with bribery no longer an option the cia
recruited an army of mercenaries to
infiltrate guatemala and carry out
guerilla attacks
they set up training camps in nicaragua
and about 150 men were trained in
sabotage demolition and weapon training
the liberation army was born
a cia operation codenamed pb success
mobilized disaffected exiles and
peasants into action meanwhile
a special cia unit planted soviet marked
weapons inside guatemala ready to be
quote unquote discovered as proof that
communism was taking over central
america just in case you need to justify
your actions in an international
courtroom the cia also began to sneak
planes into neighboring countries the
goal a terror campaign to force
arabenza's army into some mission
what we wanted to do was have a terror
campaign to terrify our bench
particularly terrify his his troops much
as the german stuka bombers terrified
the population of holland belgium and
poland at the onset of world war ii
and just rendered everybody paralyzed
now the cia needed one more key actor a
guatemalan exile who would lead the
liberation army but they couldn't just
pick any bloodthirsty man once the
invasion was over the leading general
would most likely take over the
government and the last thing the cia
wanted was another hothead who did what
he wanted the cia needed someone they
can control a puppet who would work for
u.s interests and in castillo armas a
military commander they found the
perfect man for the job
bloodthirsty corrupt and willing to
serve american interests
now all the cia needed was the perfect
excuse to set off the invasion
may 15 1954 around 9 a.m a cargo ship
arrived in one of guatemala's port
cities the cargo weapons worth over 1
million dollars straight from
czechoslovakia it was otabenza's
desperate attempt to get ready for the
invasion he knew was coming but if he
thought he could buy weapons undetected
by the cia he was badly mistaken the cia
knew about his interest in these weapons
for over a year but instead of spreading
panic the cia was relieved they had been
trying to find a good excuse for a long
time to unleash the liberation army the
cia had already begun to plant weapons
with soviet markings inside guatemala
but u.s critics may see through the
trick so the cargo ship full of czech
weapons was a gift sent from heaven it
was the final proof they needed
guatemala was doing business with the
communists a day later the cia had a
quick meeting to discuss the situation
and they all came to the same conclusion
arbenz now had enough weapons to crush
his neighbors and take over central
america
even president eisenhower warned that
the arrival of czech weapons in
guatemala might lead to a quote
communist dictatorship on this continent
to the detriment of all american nations
end quote with the green light of the us
president the cia set the invasion date
for june 18th
[Music]
june 18 1954 after the liberation army
demanded that our bans must resign
airstrikes in and around guatemala city
were launched
fighter jets kept coming out of nowhere
and even attacked a school riddling it
with machine gun fire as the airstrikes
continued the cia's puppet general
castillo armas advanced into guatemala
with his troops
but things weren't going so well for the
general they failed to take over key
cities and our benefits army was able to
push them back
to make things worse one of the pilots
had the task to bomb a radio station in
guatemala city but the pilot attacked
the wrong station the one occupied by
americans it was a total disaster they
were failing on almost all fronts to
prevent the mission from collapsing the
cia had to act quick they flat out told
eisenhower that they had to send more
fighter jets or operation success would
fail under huge pressure to save the
mission the president gave the go-ahead
this time cia pilots picked their
targets more carefully they bombed
military stations oil reserves and
several key cities while president avenz
and his army were slowly pushed into a
corner
out of pure desperation guatemala's
foreign minister sent a message to the
u.s secretary of state asking for
support but they just shrugged their
shoulders and turned up the
psychological warfare
at night they played tapes of bombing
attacks over large speakers to cause
even more panic and fear
and just in case that wasn't enough the
cia's propaganda radio spread fake news
that arbenza's army was defeated and
that general castillo armas was leading
an army of 5 000 men
even though he never had more than 400
men under his command it was
psychological warfare at its finest and
guatemala was close to defeat to make
things worse president arbenza's army
began to crack under the pressure his
commanders began accepting bribes and
one of his commanders allegedly
surrendered his troops for sixty
thousand dollars
on june 25th president arbenz made one
last desperate attempt he wanted to hand
out weapons to everyone who was willing
to fight for him but the next day he
heard the shocking news
no one was willing to go to war for him
without an army or any support the end
was near
[Music]
a few days into the invasion the cia
decided that it was time for the final
big lie they spread the news that two
large armies were on their way to
surround guatemala city fearing for
their lives people began to flee the
city and president arbenz was now at the
mercy of the united states shortly after
he got his final ultimatum he had until
4 pm to leave the national palace and
turn over power if he was still
president by the end of the day they
would bomb him into the ground
arbenz realized that if he refused to
leave it would only end up in more
battles and the loss of many lives
so on june 27th at around 9 00 pm he
addressed his people via radio for the
last time
they have used the pretext of
anti-communism the truth is very
different the truth is to be found in
the financial interests of the fruit
company and the other u.s monopolies
which have invested great amounts of
money in latin america
at around midnight former president
arbenz walked down the steps of the
national palace one last time and went
into exile
[Music]
[Music]
the coup was followed by some of the
darkest times in guatemalan history
[Music]
desperate and defeated the former
president first fled to mexico restless
and mostly unwelcomed he moved with his
wife and three children from country to
country including switzerland france
russia and uruguay
then fidel castro invited him to live in
cuba but arbenz was too exhausted and
depressed to fight in another revolution
he also had problems with his favorite
daughter arabella she had refused to
follow him to cuba which already caused
him great pain but then his darkest
nightmare came true during an evening
out of bogota in colombia she had an
argument with her boyfriend she was so
furious that she walked right up to him
pulled out a gun and shot herself in
front of him
she was only 25 years old
during the funeral akobo arbenz leaned
over his daughter's coffin and whispered
i will be with you soon my little
daughter
on january 27 1971 adebanz drowned in
his bathtub at his mexican home
guatemala's fate was equally dark right
after the invasion general castillo
armas became guatemala's new president
he reversed the land reform and most
citizens suffered great poverty once
again but his reign was short-lived
one evening in july 1957 he went out to
have dinner with his wife out of nowhere
a stranger showed up and shot him
several times
he collapsed and died within seconds but
he didn't make things better for the
poor country
one corrupt regime after the other took
over and terror poverty and political
assassinations dominated the country
death squads sponsored by the military
regime roamed the country freely people
were kidnapped or killed in the streets
on a daily basis
anyone who protested anyone who dared to
challenge the military regime suffered
the same fate
torture and inevitable death
in the decade after 1966 tens of
thousands of people were kidnapped
tortured and killed all with the
blessing of the us and the cia
what the cia doesn't like to admit is
that the invasion of guatemala almost
fail which is kind of embarrassing since
we're talking about the us versus a
small country in central america but in
2011 one u.s mission was a huge success
the raid on osama bin laden after the
seals had assassinated bin laden they
discovered something drastic in his
compound a treasure trove of computers
hard drives notebooks and printed files
lying around on every floor these files
could contain priceless intelligence it
took the seals an extra 18 minutes to
collect this treasure trove of 500 000
digital and physical files
this intel collection would become known
as the bin laden papers for years most
of those files were kept classified but
in 2017 the cia finally declassified
over 470 000 of those files for the
world to see and what they contained was
shocking to say the least but here's the
thing a video that goes this deep into
bin laden's life his attacks and his
plans for the world is guaranteed to get
demonetized so that's why we just
released a brand new private documentary
going over the bin laden papers in all
its infinity the video has already been
age restricted and channel members have
been loving the documentary all you have
to do to get access to this documentary
right now and all the other documentary
length videos that are too controversial
too dark too risky to post publicly is
to click the join button below once you
sign up you'll get exclusive access to
the bin laden papers plus others like
every up scene monsanto the company that
owns the world's food supply mk ultra
and many more in the future these are
the things they should be teaching you
in university about how the world works
but unlike university you get all of
this for just five dollars a month
and what's even better is that if you
join and you don't think it's worth it
email me and i'll personally refund you
the money for the last month you paid
pause the video and click that join
button below right now
i don't know about you guys but i find
these cia intervention videos super
super fascinating so if you have any
ideas on what other crazy cia stories we
should do next let me know in the
comments below if you're new here my
name is jake and this is one of the
biggest channels on youtube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime so if you enjoyed this video we
make multiple documentaries just like
this one for free every single week so
click the subscribe button below don't
forget to follow me on instagram for a
chance to win a thousand dollars at jake
tran watch out for fake accounts but
that's gonna wrap it up stay dangerous
out there and i'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
[Music]
you